so I've just spent recently 11,000
pounds to receive a day we've Gary
Vaynerchuk
I mean I don't know whoever I'm gonna
get a really good return on investment
or not but I love Gary Vaynerchuk he's a
massive inspiration to me and if I can
pick his brain all day about business
investments marketing you know he's
worth a lot of money and he does what he
does very very well so if I can get one
nugget I think it'll be worth the eleven
thousand pounds so let's see how it goes
I'll be documenting the journey today
[Music]
I'm really uh no no you have to burn it
there's a single reason why I'm winning
I've only given advice I've lived it is
the best way to go about it if you
decide to build your brand in any way
yeah don't reach don't assume or guess
or borrow I know nothing about what
anybody else says I don't nothing like
you'd be blown away by how much is the
I've never consumed anything about
anybody just always gave it like she
lived that's why people get benefit from
it you've already seen it work and then
when you get good and realize what
you're unique about so that you can
hedge in because I'm a calm extroverted
so this won't work for an introvert or
high-risk this like have any get better
at the way you give it because you start
nuancing it yeah yeah so if you've got a
personal brand I'm really quite excited
about the yes a lot of people really
excited about it I've no idea how good
document a deliver I'm gonna do it by
blog style or make more professional
documentary with neck come up yeah
get Nick Rick have two different films
people they're like big book documentary
yeah
Rick do this block okay and do this
twice yeah we have that long as I'm
going forward you did Michael birth yeah
I think what you'll need to do for the
documentary or the thing that's a longer
production is find an angle that isn't
being played out in day to day and vlog
so that it makes the core group want to
watch that as well
yeah needs to be a behind the scenes
maybe yeah maybe right they can hear the
connector gary via blogs of gary
vaynerchuck in the documentary a
documentary of you mean you even I've
given you a lot of glimpse to it here
and all of your like oh [ __ ] yeah right
the smartest of you this woman oh wait a
minute
yeah like it's way more serious than I
actually thought yeah because I've given
you four or five data points to like
show you I'm like showing you a little
like that got it you might be able to do
that yeah you might be able to star it
in the blog and be envied the master
lines behind it yes in the dock also and
what you can do in the dock then this
also say and look let's not forget I did
come with my knowledge yeah I started 0
like yeah I can start at 0 and win every
time too because I've got the IP yeah
that's the difference [ __ ] I love that
like without you acknowledging that
undermines your entire premise yeah like
cool you start at 0
[ __ ] out ten years of experience you
know exactly what to look for yeah
that's why I can't do it from kitchen
mom Susan I don't know [ __ ] about ten
years of experience yeah
it can also be a launching pad for you
to put out three content of the nuances
of the show year's show okay see where
I'm going I love that you guys carry me
Samuels big challenges coming if you're
as excited as d-roc is you're [ __ ]
pumped
[Music]